in this segment we justify some of the
properties of the correlation
coefficient that we claimed a little
earlier the most important properties
that the correlation coefficient lies
between minus 1 and plus 1 we will prove
this property for the special case where
we have random variables with zero means
and unit variance --is so standard
deviations are also 1 so most of the
terms here disappear and the correlation
coefficient is simply the expected value
of x times y we will show that in this
special case the expected value of x
times y lies between minus 1 and 1 but
the proof of this fact remains valid
with a little bit of more algebra and
long similar lines for the general case
what we will do is we will consider this
quantity here and expand this quadratic
and write it as expected value of x
squared then there is a cross term which
is minus 2 Rho the expected value of x
times y plus Rho squared expected value
of y squared now since we assume that
the random variables have zero mean this
is the same as the variance and we
assume that the variance is 1 so this
term here is equal to 1 now the expected
value of x times y is the same as the
correlation coefficient in this case so
we have minus 2 Rho squared and from
here we have Rho squared and by the
previous argument again this quantity
according to our assumptions is equal to
1 so we're left with this expression
which is 1 minus Rho squared now notice
that this is the expectation of a
non-negative random variable so this
quantity here must be non-negative
therefore 1 minus Rho squared is
non-negative
which means that Rho squared is less
than or equal to one and that's the same
as requiring the TRO lie between minus
one and plus one and so we have
established this important property at
least for the special case of zero means
and unit variances but as I mentioned it
remains valid
more generally now let us look at an
extreme case when the absolute value
overall is equal to one what happens in
this case in that case this term is 0
and this implies that the expected value
of the square of this random variable is
equal to 0 now here we have a
non-negative random variable and it's
expected value is 0 which means that
when we calculate the expected value of
this there will be no positive
contributions and so the only
contributions must be equal to 0 this
means that X minus R or Y has to be
equal to 0 with probability 1 so X is
going to be equal to Rho times y and
this will happen with essential
certainty now also because the absolute
value of Rho is equal to 1 this means
that we have either X equal to Y or X
equal to minus y in case Rho is equal to
minus 1 so we see that if the
correlation coefficient has an absolute
value of 1 then x and y are related to
each other according to a simple linear
relation and it's an extreme form of
dependence between the two random
variables